let's have a look at one first and the
first thing we say is if question one
were a multiple choice question if
question one more a multiple choice
question then this would be one of the
answers this would be a B C or D okay
has anyone a different answer to it okay
now a half would be another one of the
answers okay when we provide when we
provide multiple choice solutions what
we try and give is what's pretty close
like we weren't where try and like
randomly guess our numbers that like you
would never get what we want is to
introduce like one error or two in there
and then use those as our solutions now
x equals 2 solo very very close okay
let's just have a look at this line by
line what have we done to go from here
from the first line to the second what
has been done to my son great fantastic
so we wanted to get rid of this which is
a good mood so multiplication by 2 will
do that okay so far so good 92 93 what's
been done okay i think is extension
right the left hand side is not changed
it's just the right hand side we want to
get rid of the brackets why is getting
rid of the rack is a good idea because
where are we trying to go what do we
want to find a line to be we wanted to
be empty calls right except there's like
X is tucked in there that we need to get
out of there so therefore we expend that
makes sense is that the correct
expansion for this lad yeah good we've
doubled that will double that or group
okay this next lines a bit tricky a
couple of things different couple of
different things happen what are the two
things that have a 10 from the next
thanks
and then for the +1 okay so you can say
this in a couple of different ways you
can talk about removing the TEDx over
there even though that does work out I
prefer to say I'm adding 10 X to both
sides because it's an equation right we
want to do the same thing that does give
you 14 X and then in the same way we'll
add 1 to both sides and that does give 7
so we're all fine up into here okay now
how does too don't tell me whether it's
right or wrong how does to emerge from
this line into this line what would you
do to get to you would divide by 7 now
that's a common thing to do because when
we think of division we usually divided
big numbers by small numbers usually but
should i do that in this case no I
actually is in this insane I should / 14
so let's actually just add that in if i
divide this by 14 that would give me an
X if i divide this by 14 I'll almost get
two I'll get a half do you agree okay so
you see why like so much has been done
right it was very close but you've got
to be careful with little solutions like
that one last thing that I knew before i
actually did not the answers what I
understand one of those I could look at
that and instantly know something was
wrong is because if i just take to just
take two and just have a look at what it
might be at the top okay now don't even
need to know the values over here right
three take away five times two that's
going to be a negative number right I
don't know what it is but it'd be
negative okay over here four times two
minus one that's going to be positive
you divide by 2 it will still be
positive so there's a mismatch I don't
even know there's no how much of a
mismatch it is I just need to know that
it is one so that makes me reinvested it
and so where did something go wrong and
that's why I working is so important
thumbs up make sense okay can I get a
suggestion for the volume anyone want to
be great stick their hand up yeah Oh
joining me to give you the number and
then we'll go from there um
I'm in heart and six have you
approximate have you got like used to
cancel yeah yeah actually I do you want
me then art 1 1130 coins 1130 point when
what on something different don't want
to get a different answer I've got two
thousand ten point six do I get more
agreeable that one we're good old
differences yeah what did you get how
many got that okay we've got a few heads
up right let's confirm so I pose this
question I posted a question to everyone
and it's a bit sneaky I said if you had
to pick a shape that this was closest to
what would it be and you could obviously
could take to sell none like the big
things are sold out but maybe an easier
way to think about it is it kind of fits
just like all of the other prisons that
we've looked at right what makes a
prison of prison do you remember yeah
good so if I slice across and get the
same shape every time what do we call
that shape by the way if you slice
across we call a cross-section right
because that's what actually section
means it means cut and cross means
across so you can see if I cut all the
way across what would you get by the way
what would you call that you kind of get
like a yes or no Sona on this disk sort
of thing it's actually the special name
I don't know if you remember I gave me a
couple of times ago it's called an
annulus um so you get one of these every
single time so I can treat this as a
prison therefore here's one way I could
work out the volume right I could say
what's the area of the cross section
that's the important part how do I work
out the air of the cross section yeah
you work out the area of the top bid
assuming the middle holes not there and
you figure out there middle oh and you
monitor okay good so there's two circles
up there yeah there's two circles so one
of the circles will be PI R squared
what's the big radius so i'm going to
use any six and then I'm going to take
away another PI R square
but what's that PI R squared it's going
to be x 2 square okay so that'll give
you that whatever that happens to be
that's your cross section okay and then
I multiply that by the fight and you can
check if you get that the outlet the
thickest so who was killed right look em
so we could have figured out pulling
with other things like it was a deer
yeah yeah yeah so you're gonna we're
going to come to the same answer if
you've punched numbers correctly because
you'll do the big cylinder right and
then you're going to subtract the
cylinder in the middle so it allows for
the same case you should still arrive on
yeah well you only did the inside yeah
that's a fish so so you're asking about
capacity how much stuff can i flip it
inside a container versus a volume which
is how much space does the container
take up that makes those are very
closely related questions but different
it doesn't look like a boat I realize
that a suicide really all right now I'm
surface area do we have a number for
that who wants me brave yeah Chris 7f
refresh okay do I have some agreement on
that one yeah thumbs up okay heads down
yeah just before we leave this because
I'm happy with that number two it looks
about right what is this number composed
of like where do one of the pieces that
go into this okay um how many areas do
you count that maybe if you had to like
count them up one by one that make up
this surface area do you care for I
count four as well you're at the top of
the bottom which are the same okay then
you've got the outside and inside that
make sense ok so the way you're going to
do that let's do the top of the bottom
the top my mother is going to be this
isn't it like we actually already work
this out um the top will look like this
now the top of the bottom are the same
so I'm going to double that do great
okay and then I'm going to have to add
the two ones that are missing a curved
surface areas that they're so I've got a
soup our age for the big one and a two
player edge for this small world what
would that be 2pi r h that's the big one
and then this small one is too high are
a chicken okay and then obviously you
can chose numbers with your calculator
and you've done okay you happy without
make sense cool it was asked like is
this the inside isn't the outside if
you're not told anything um you should
do the whole lot including whatever's
inside okay if they should they should
be clear for you but if it's the total
area they often would say that you know
okay would you please rule that off by
the way I was really pleased that I saw
a lot of you in your diagrams they were
good sized diagrams I saw you break
apart the shape into the different
components which is big thumbs up